i want to pull up this tweet because uh
we were talking about
um you know like law and stuff came up
and i was thinking about this in the
context of where we're going civil war
wise
marion williamson was responding to a
newsweek story about trump getting his
special master that they're going to
review the documents seized and she said
this is terrible news why is that
terrible stick's hexahammer says how sad
that your witch hunt nonsense is being
put on hold for due process reasons she
responded does the law matter to you at
all or do you just think it doesn't
apply to him
now here's the problem marion williamson
i actually i think she's very nice sweet
lady but this is the issue with the left
they don't care about facts at all they
care about how they feel
so they ignore facts they don't do
research and my response
the law stopped being relevant when
democrats impeached trump over joe biden
threatening the ukrainian president with
illegally blocking us aid guarantees or
maybe it was when they fabricated
evidence to spy on trump the funny thing
is
people like marian williamson don't know
that happened telling her doesn't matter
because it gives her a negative
emotional response you were wrong your
facts are bad and you're on the wrong
side negative emotional response don't
want to listen to you get away from me
they only want sweet comforting lies
well they want sweet comfort
no they want life they prefer lies look
look whether whether they intentionally
say i want lies or a lie is what makes
them feel better and they request so
they're like make me feel better yeah i
love that line from v for vendetta where
he says would you prefer a lie or the
truth
when when uh he gets asked by evie about
you
they want hope
to kill that man what was the so what is
the situation here what law what is
being discussed she says there's no due
proc there's there's no rule of law so
donald trump there is they seize the
documents trump says a special master
should review this to make sure they're
not going through private stuff they're
not allowed to like
privileged documents
and she thinks you should not have due
process
she's scared that the that the appointee
is going to be somewhat on his side that
they're going to help him out and she's
also scared of lengthening this out
before he announces whether or not he's
going to run for president so if they if
they have a hitter that they can use on
trump before he puts in his candidacy
they want it now
right and it's so sorry let me squeeze
this one real fast it is so telling to
me that they don't want it to be
possible for someone to like
donald trump's perspective no insane
he's already convicted in their minds
like for sure he committed a crime we're
just not totally sure what the crime is
is the logic there so why he would need
due process is sort of beyond ken to
them because
he shouldn't he should already be
convicted they don't want anything
holding this up because right he is
already you know personal grouda enemy
number one there's no recovering from
that he doesn't deserve the law a big
mistake people are making i think is
that they're pinning a lot of social
distress right now on political parties
like which is it the republicans causing
this chaos or is it the democrats but in
reality when you look at videos in like
sri lanka or in italy where people are
rioting on the street and smashing stuff
and attacking cops it's because they
don't have heat they don't have
electricity that's what's causing and
going to cause civil stress in this
country it really doesn't matter who's
in political power at that stage but
everyone is going to say like well you
know you why you don't have the things
that you need to survive because of that
other party i uh vladimir putin did this
interview today where he was like yeah
europe is sacrificing all of their
people uh to keep them uh american
globalist elite in uh dominant power
like he is saying the exact same thing
we are all looking for someone else to
blame issues on but like with all of the
sanctions and energy bills are high you
can understand where that that line is
now going to potentially be persuasive
to at least russians if not other people
who are like yeah our leadership is
really messing us up here how are we
going to get over what is it the system
they don't want i i hate using the term
today it's so vague but power structures
don't want people to be in power don't
want people to have unlimited
electricity because then they'll have
more power than the government and rise
up and overthrow so they've kept this in
a state of slaveocracy but that's going
to cause people to rise up it's like in
one of the greatest movie franchises of
all time fast and furious great
goodness i think fundamentally a wise
man once said the villain in one of them
i'm not sure if it was five or not he
said you know you give the people
something that they're that they're
scared to lose you could take away and
then you control them then they're
slaves that was my thought yeah so it's
basically like give them just enough you
make their lives better and then they're
dependent upon you it's like it's like
it's like
you know it's not all bad in a sense
where you're making their lives a little
better but then you're also using it
specifically for control yeah it's like
a tyrannosaurus rex and hoping it
doesn't realize that
it's a t-rex and you're just a little
guy well it's like uh there's there's
this famous meme where there's a big
elephant with like a rope on its foot
little spike in the ground and someone
said why won't the elephant just rip it
out and and walk away and they said when
the elephant was little it struggled and
fought and learned that it couldn't get
out now that it's older it doesn't even
bother trying and on top of that they're
they're also pushing this message of you
need to do this this is the this is for
the greater good like with this energy
stuff that's happening right now
entangled in that is the climate crisis
and hysteria surrounding that so not
only are you giving the government
control but you're doing it for a good
cause you're doing the right thing which
is exactly what's happening in the
netherlands right now you know the
farmers are are up in arms about their
their livelihoods being taken away and
it is just a massive land grab from the
government but the government is saying
no it's for climate change this line
flattened the curve like covet taught us
you referenced the rat hoaxer it's
really pavlov's a dog they ring the bell
oh we got a flat in the curves and
everyone should fall in line and do this
because it's for the greater good that's
right so the rat the rat hope experiment
we've talked about a bit before
guy takes three rats three cylinders
puts the rats in the cylinders they swim
for 15 minutes can't get out and then
they just give up sink and die
then he takes another pair of rats set
of rats puts them in they swim 15
minutes or so they give up but this time
he lifts them out
dries them off lets them relax
then puts them back in the second time
they swam for 60 hours
so we talked about this during the covet
lockdown are they going to rat
experiment us you put us in lockdown
everybody starts losing their minds and
then right before it gets too bad you
stop you let everybody go back to normal
you bring the movies back you bring the
video games back the food's back the
pizza's back the wings are back
and then
you give everybody a little bit to relax
dry off and then do it again and now
they'll last 60 60 times as long so if
you went let's put it this way 15
minutes to 60 hours
we're talking about what is it like a
200 uh
was it 20 what are we doing 240 times
240 time increase so uh
based on the fact they locked us down
for what a year
are they now going to start pulling hard
back for another couple hundred years it
doesn't need to be that much it doesn't
need to translate you only need a
generation
because you lock down the the generation
of people that are used to living well
and have access to technology
once they accept their fate and say if
we just stay at it and flatten the curve
then eventually things will get better
that's right that i think people the
kids born into it will be like this is
not well in slavery they never have and
they've always there's just a history of
uprising against slavery whether it's a
monarchy or a corporation or whatever
like i i can't imagine that people would
sit still for very long
don't try and control is there is there
like a form of soft totalitarianism
where it's like you you are somewhat
enslaved but you have all these
wonderful amenities to keep you at bay
and to keep you docile and you have your
streaming services and you have just
enough ac to keep your house cool and
you know just enough to be fine in the
place that you're at and without enough
energy to really realize how oppressed
you are yeah they have to slowly take
away from you because the idea is you
will own nothing and you will be happy
that's right and but but this is true
okay that's a true statement
you will own nothing and you will be
happy is true
you so we right now
are not unhappy that we don't have
access to flying cars and teleportation
i mean speak for yourself no i know some
people are like i wish i could teleport
but what i mean is
you uh we mentioned this a little while
ago there was a video of a 90 year old
man in like the turn of the century 20
1900s they recorded him he was alive in
the civil war and they were like what's
it like with all this you know how was
it for you growing up with all the
technology now like the same
people get by they do the work they got
to do we got by just fine people get by
now we are we are accustomed to
technology we have we are not upset that
we don't have technology we don't know
exists so if they can take it away from
you and then
remove it from your thoughts or the next
generation grows up without having it
they won't be unhappy because they won't
know it existed yeah i forget what
podcast i was watching this week but
they were talking about how it's
humanity's greatest strength and our
greatest weakness that we can get used
to anything so there really hasn't been
a lot of humans thriving in slavery but
people do get used to it i don't know if
you remember and i'm sure ian doesn't
know but in the bible the israelites
escaped slavery and they were so upset
in the desert they were like why can't
we go back to slavery that was better at
least we were fed right yeah this is a
thing that happens to humans and has
been happening since we came here i mean
look at young people during this coveted
pandemic being locked down how quickly
they were like oh i'm totally fine being
home also let's work from home now and
the way our workforce is shifted
subsequently it's we are very quickly
and you saw i used to see a lot of
content that was like somebody asked me
to get lunch before they're pandemic and
you're like running errands you're doing
stuff and then after the pandemic like
you have one social interaction you're
like i'm not for the year i can't do
anything
it literally became something that
people are overwhelmed by when it was
actually a huge part of civilization
working in community and having regular
contact with other people like we are
now more isolated and the pandemic just
made it so we acclimated faster yeah but
we're more connected through the
internet right guys i love you the
the training worked but i also think
it's a big marketing campaign it's a big
psyop so you do remote work i'm actually
not not uh as opposed to remote work for
a lot of jobs some jobs require
community and and and you know cohesion
but for a lot of jobs like yeah you can
work from home for a lot of this stuff
now you've got people who are i don't
want to go back to work i want to work
from home
yeah that's good for everything that's
going on like reducing carbon emissions
all the climate change stuff all the
energy stuff they put people in a
position for a year then people get
accustomed to it and then beg for it
again that's what they like social
social manipulation social engineering
and this would be
i don't want to put too much weight on
the world economic forum but i don't
know who else they're working with but
the idea that people are going into the
pods that we're creating like a race of
borg people pod people that are people
brains are hooked to the to the machine
and we're all kind of seeing each
other's thoughts and working as one
because the other the other option is
total chaos and uprisings of people
thinking they don't have enough thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you